[Musica]
[Applauso]
è che sì mi si sa cosa sta facendo la
festeggiamo il compleanno
che si mi si sta festeggiando il
compleanno ma qualche armi ma che se
messi non lo so 127
che sta succedendo
[Musica]
[Applauso]
il nostro libro i professori paurosa
irpini non regolato gli uochi dobbiamo
riprendercelo se sapete che il libro ha
dei poteri e in mani sbagliate potrebbe
essere catastrofi soprattutto nelle mani
di agno anche chi si disse dobbiamo
riprenderlo subito
sì ho troppa paura che qui ci veda ma
soprattutto a me vedi non c'è abbastanza
spazio quindi per nascondermi block e
goditi ma dobbiamo
vitale il solito fifone e ha voluto
andare a nascondersi di no e il solito
fifoni vabbè proverò io riprendere il
libro mentre lui è nascosto forse se mi
nascondo qui non mi vedranno quindi
magari
mi metto qui dietro questo scivolo
comodo
[Musica]
si nasconde un po come
posso schiacciare un pisolino
[Musica]
va
[Applauso]
cos'era questo rumore
niente c'è troppo sonno bru
per fortuna non riescono dentro
non riescono ad entrare quando
ok si sono allontanati finalmente per
fortuna non possono entrare qua dentro
siamo al sicuro devo assolutamente
recuperare il mio libro storie paurose
avete visto l'hanno lasciato lì sul
trono del tata parti a proposito grazie
da da forti per averci ospitato di nuovo
se volete festeggiare il vostro
compleanno assolutamente dovete
festeggiarlo qualità da porti perché è
bellissimo ha un sacco di giochi un
sacco di sale e ora presto continuiamo
la sua legge dobbiamo recuperare il
libro storie paurose che voi ce l'avete
l'avete preso crive simili commenti se
l'avete preso ma vitale dove sarà ancora
lì nascosto ora che si sono allontanati
per uscire da qua e cercare di non
essere presa
ma chi è che chi stilisti non li vedo
più
molto strano c'è molto silenzio io provo
ad andare là dove c'era il trono e provo
a riprendermi il libro il mio libro ma
lei non c'è nessuno ne dubita ma
proviamo che sembra che non ci sia
nessuno qua bene viali
[Musica]
e laggiù non riuscivo mai a prenderlo
meglio a scappare
aiuto
ok se non riuscite a scappare questa
volta erano un po più lenti del solito
forse quando si illuminano gli occhi
puoi dire che sono più lenti ci sono a
di wadi e chisti misti che fanno la
guardia può trovare un'altra soluzione
per recuperare il libro devo distrarli
con qualcosa
guardate un palloncino ovvero a
distrarli con questo dopotutto è il
compleanno di chi si
missile farà piacere ricevere un
palloncino del suo colore ma chi guardi
che si inizi a un regalino per voi
dove siete pupazzi malefici
capisco
gli wally
chi si vive vorrei fare uno scambio cioè
io vi do questo palloncino rosa e voi
meritate il mio libro storie paurose
cosa ne pensate
guardate sono usciti inter perché mi
stavano cercando world
io pensavo che voi non riuscisse entrare
là dentro
e poi ci riuscite
tiri queste per te non mangiarli
sembra contenta
[Musica]
regalo per esamineranno
che succede
ma minuta bene perché questa reazione io
ti ho fatto un regalo per il compleanno
perché mi stai seguendo molto
[Musica]
prendiamo che pro prestiti per qua
equilibro
preso
[Applauso]
ma devo capire come uscire da qua e poi
devo riuscire a riprendere il mio libro
potrebbe rito vitale potrebbe aiutarmi
[Musica]
chi è che chiusa la
ecco poi la vita è bisogno di me perché
aiuto
e dove riferito stavo cercando di
watkins missiva dietro perché mi è
sembrato di vedere scappare la dietro
allora sono andato a controllare
basta di 1 dic i servizi erano qua e mi
hanno rifiuta qua dentro davvero
quindi ci sono due anni luoghi 2 kissi
missy no secondo me solo che non li
stavi cercando proprio per niente e dai
sbrigati vivere ops
scoperto liberebbe dormendo ceo adesso
di libro spiega ha detto stava agito a
new age stavo dormendo tira l'ho visto
prima perché allora per liberare un di
liberarti aspetta
un martello con il martello mosso aprire
adesso lo sfondo lo bello
[Musica]
ci sono kissi mi sia di omagh in giro
non sono ancora riuscito a prendere il
libro iniziamo un piano vai a
nasconderti là dentro evitiamo così loro
a chi vuoi che se misti arriveranno li a
cercarti nel frattempo si io uscirò qua
fuori prenderò il libro poi ti chiamo
devi correre subito qua e li vediamo qua
dentro con il cancello che è pronto a un
settore marittimo
lui mi nascondo guadagno
una volta che vitale chiama di vuoti e
chiesti misti io correrò di la prenderò
il libro e poi chiudere il cancello
vitale al mio tre fiamma b ok
123 il pbd
oggi quanti guai
guai
eccoli stato ri tanto
ho chiesto non posso prendere vitale
preso in pugno
sta sta chiamando scappiamo scappiamo
[Applauso]
[Musica]
giudizi ora voi se ti chiudi l'ho detto
e noi abbiamo
il libro è nostro ha detto
[Musica]
più di niente
vi ricordiamo che star e paura tra
scuola di mystery era disponibile in
libreria online versi e se volete
festeggiare la vostra festa di
compleanno in un posto per mega
fantastico ovviamente festeggiate
d'acqua